dans cette résidence privée pour un nez
de têteform minds 25% des chambres sont
inoccupées sur 40 j'en ai quasiment
c'est pas la place qui manque alors que
les urgences se débordent le
gouvernement fait appel au RPA on n'a
pas assez de lique sont ouverts parce
qu'on manque de personnes le ministre
souhaite acheter des places dans les RPA
pour y transférer les patients qui n'ont
plus besoin de soins aigus dans les
hôpitaux
[Musique]
je le fais déjà avec des convalescences
des réparations de genou des
je pense que ça serait adéquat aussi la
proposition semble aussi bien accueillie
dans le milieu hospitalier
ta chambre il y a des toutes les
infections nosocomiales je pense qu'elle
est si patients-là serait mieux à
l'extérieur mais dans la grande région
de Québec l'application pourrait être
ardues
177 patients qui remplissent
occupe des lits dans les cinq principaux
hôpitaux en chaudière à palaches ils
sont 83 répartis dans les quatre
hôpitaux de la région
qui ont fermé puis en plus on a eu moins
de nouvelles ouvertures si vous voulez
de grands RPA le détail de la mesure n'a
pas encore été annoncé mais le
Regroupement québécois des résidences
pour un nid demandent déjà un soutien
financier et du personnel la
main-d'oeuvre on n'est pas capable
d'augmenter des salaires parce qu'on n'a
pas les revenus qui viennent avec
deuxième élément à ça c'est que des
employés des CLSC probablement viennent
aider pour ces patients-là à moins que
la RPE avec soin et tous ces employés
actuellement au Québec plus de 2000
litres sont occupés par des patients qui
ne nécessitent pas de soins en centre
hospitalier cela représente 13% de tous
les lits au Québec alors que les salles
d'attente des urgences sont pleine à
craquer ici Magali mas son Radio-Canada
Québec